[Music]
over 90 percent of all software contains
open source components leveraging open
source accelerates adding capabilities
to your app's delivery velocity and can
provide cost savings but when you use
open source software you are depending
on someone else's code which you don't
control and you often don't understand
its full provenance this expands your
attack surface and risk securing the
breadth of Open Source Code you depend
on is hard and complex at Google we
continue to be one of the largest
maintainers contributors and users of
Open Source and are deeply involved in
helping make the open source software
ecosystem more secure
our new assured open source software
service assured OSS offered you the
ability to obtain the key open source
software packages you need from Google
as your known and trusted supplier
cured according to our best practices
processes and security testing saving
yourself toil maintenance headaches and
complexity
the resources or experience to construct
and operate a comprehensive and
centralized open source software
security program your development teams
might be individually deciding sometimes
in silos where they get third-party
source code and packages how they are
built and how they are redistributed
within the organization
you can change this simply if you have
your teams include assured open source
software as a default Repository
do a central logical consistent control
Point since assured open source software
packages have consistent end-to-end
build security which leverages proven
Google best practices continuous
security scanning and testing enriched
metadata including vulnerability and
Licensing info and tamper evidence salsa
provenance and evidence assured open
source software lets you easily
incorporate the same open source
software packages and the same open
source software security that Google
uses into your own developer workflows
are regularly scanned analyzed and fuzz
tested for vulnerabilities they have
corresponding enriched metadata
including package Health vulnerability
impact and Licensing data in standard
formats
packages are built end to end with
Google best practices and include
evidence of verifiable salsa compliance
they are verifiably signed and
distributed from a Google managed
secured and protected artifact registry
using assured open source software you
can choose from more than one thousand
of the most popular Java and python
packages including common ml AI projects
like tensorflow pandas and scikit-learn
know more about your ingredients with
assured s-bombs provided in Industry
standard formats like spdx and vex
reduce risk as Google actively scans
finds and works with the community to
fix new vulnerabilities in curated
packages increase confidence in the
Integrity of the ingredients you're
using through signed tamper evident
Providence and obtain your open source
software packages from a trusted and
known supplier Google
assured OSS allows organizations and
individuals to directly use the secured
open source software packages Google
uses itself and to benefit from Google's
open source software security best
practices processes and testing applied
to key open source software packages
they depend on you can use assured OSS
at no cost sign up see how easy it is to
integrate into your CI CD Pipeline with
our quick start guide and see the
current packages in our portfolio just
follow the link on screen and in the
video's description
thank you for watching
[Music]
foreign